our next guest grew up reading the
encyclopedia for fun I read the
dictionary I think we're going to be
besties oh but she went on to be
nominated for a Nobel Peace Prize well
that's where we differ knowledge is a
very powerful thing please welcome the
amazing honestly a true Game Changer
Stacy Abrams
[Applause]
[Applause]
it's I'm sitting in front of Ever After
so oh my God
that changed my life mine too so I can
quote the entire film to you but we
don't have that kind of time today well
we should make time for that and it is
so surreal to see you in person because
I've watched you so closely over the
years because I I am very passionate
about voting and and that it's necessary
to do whatever party you vote for
whoever you vote for you vote I'm part
of my job and I run for office yes but
my first responsibility is to make sure
anyone who wants to vote can who's
eligible I want you to vote for me when
you get in there but but protecting
democracy is not about a person it's
about the ideals our democracy is this
Collective hallucination we have where
we say we're going to work together to
help each other and if anyone sort of
blinks and comes out of it like the
Matrix it starts to fall apart and
that's why it's so vital that regardless
of who you vote for your voice matters
because your silence is also permission
and we have to remember that the fun the
reason voting was denied to so many for
so long women people of color young
people non-property owners every time we
advance access to the vote advancing
access to society you're advancing
access to the policies that make your
life better or worse well and that's why
I won't go away I get good and nobody
wants you to you need to stay around
galvanizer now at the commercial break I
said something about you have an Excel
spreadsheet yes that you've been keeping
since you were a teenager will you
please tell me what that means and what
that is so when I was in college I fell
in love with a boy who was mean to me
um oh God yeah yeah you know what we've
all done that yeah well he broke up with
me and he said that I was too ambitious
and wanted too many things and I would
end up alone and lonely and so I got
really mad and then I was like fine I'm
gonna figure out all the things I'm
going to do to make him Rue the day that
he was mean to me and so I this was now
I'm old I'm 49. so I'm going to be 48
we're right next to each other so you'll
appreciate this this was before Excel
this is when it was Lotus one two three
right okay you had to go to the computer
lab because owning a computer meant that
you could buy the world right I went to
the computer lab at Spelman and I did a
spreadsheet and I laid out all the
things I was going to accomplish in all
the ways I was going to just be
fantastic and magnificent and I don't
know if he's ever going to see it but
I'm I'm doing okay I'm I'm doing okay on
my Sprite
on that list do you think you've
achieved are there any left oh yeah so
so the way it worked when I first did it
there they're my three big goals I
wanted to be a millionaire by 30 did not
make it uh wanted to be mayor of Atlanta
changed my mind and I wanted to be a
best-selling author took a minute but
what was so important was that by giving
myself these goals I then had to figure
out what are the steps you take to get
there and what I do is by laying out the
the goal you start to realize how
important the steps are and what we do
so often is we are so fixated on the end
that we ignore all the pieces any if you
just have a goal that's called a dream
if you have steps that's called a plan
and we spend so much time dreaming we
never plan
and so my mission was to lay out my plan
and to win my goals change my plan
doesn't because my plan is always about
what are what are the foundational
pieces I need whether the next steps I
need so yes I may not win X but here are
all the things I was able to do here the
people I touched here the lives I
impacted here's the way I'm a better
person so what's next are you gonna run
again are you going like are you do we
get to look forward to this and
Galvanize again I will likely run again
[Applause]
oh my God so are you gonna go up against
some tough men who kind of don't always
play fair
well if at first you don't succeed try
try again and if it doesn't work you try
again but the issue is what did you
learn did you did you learn about
yourself what did you learn about your
opponent and making sure that you're
always remembering why you're doing it
because can you stay calm because I feel
like my inner Rebel would come out like
I am Fire Starter still I you know I
just feel like they're like I don't I
would be on that stage and I would just
be like
really
funny you should bring that ah
[Applause]
how do you keep it under control
my so when I debate when I do debates
most people think about debates I'm
fighting you no my job is to educate the
people watching the people who turn into
that debate want to learn something and
so my job is to talk to them this person
is a foil I really love that I think we
can all learn from that
[Music]